hey everyone it's Steve on Trobe with
Collider and I am here with the people
behind imaginary order you like the way
did that yeah yeah before we get started
as I was saying off-camera I want to
give a huge thank you to Kia Telluride
and all the other sponsors here for
allowing us to be in great sponsors and
allowing us to cover Sundance we're so
lucky to be here and I just want to give
a big thank you
so big series this is I believe your
first Sundance this is my first Sundance
that I've directed that's what I mean
I'm so sorry
that is my I need to you know this is
why I'm bad at my job so tonight your
world premiere and as I was saying is
that gonna go so you're not nervous at
all I wish that were true
I'm probably like the normal amount of
nervous you should be sure and I'm just
hoping I don't like pass out when I have
to enjoy the film
that's all I'm really if I can get
through that I'll be fine
you can blame it on the altitude of it
yeah that's true dehydration water huge
thank you live water with me for my
intro I think that's a good idea being
serious
have you guys seen it with an audience
yet no no really the next tonight is
really the night okay I everyone
watching this will not have seen the
movie or maybe one person will have but
how have you been telling friends and
family about the movie this is a
question for all three of you
well it's I always say it sort of like a
woman on the verge story sort of a
female American Beauty type of story
it's about a woman who basically
unravels a midlife crisis type of movie
but there's so much more to it but
that's sort of what I've been saying
sure the cliffnotes yes yeah I'm just
trying to sum it up in like a word or
sentence I've been saying the same thing
like all my friends from LA that I
talked to about it I'm like oh it's
about you know a mom and the Pacific
Palisades who's about to have a midlife
crisis and they're like Oh
get it I know that person for sure or
you picked a specific location yeah like
anywhere America oh yeah I like that you
did for that basically and I'm telling
everybody cuz everyone wants to know
imaginary order what does that mean well
this woman who's on the verge she has
you know little tics little OCD things
and she imagines that all the order that
she's making is actually making a
difference but it's not keeping her from
unraveling and visiting her old habits
from before she moved to suburbia and
had her family so she's she's dabbling
in all she's dipping her toe in the
naughty pond alright but I think of
imaginary order is anything yeah like
there is no real order this is all
pretend like this is not really border
do you know what I mean and when I wrote
the script I had moved from New York I
just moved to LA from New York and
Serbia to me always seemed like this
giant imaginary order like with all the
manicured lawns and it freaked me out
and I was always kind of phobic and you
were into teenage neighbors and boys and
stuff
well that's there's all kinds of like
little sometimes you get seduced by a
whole story that's true it happens you
get sucked in trying to avoid your own
yes exactly I am definitely curious
though talk about the initial meetings
what when you first met with everyone
and you guys are all meeting for the
first time are you super nervous the
night before because you're thinking I
really want this role I want this part
and for you are you thinking oh my god I
want her to like me because I want her
in my movie or him well it kind of was
more organic like I don't I was an
actress and I really don't like
auditions I don't think it really is
appropriate actually I think you need to
have you have to meet the person so I
met Wendy and I met max actually through
my husband who did a pilot with him and
I did a reading and I think that's the
sort of the best way to do I did a
reading of one of one of the drafts of
the script and
but Wendy was actually reading a
different role max was always reading
his role and that was sort of how we met
and when I first met saw Wendy met Wendy
I was really surprised because of her
persona on TV was so was just so I'm
quietly on show so subdued in real life
anyway I'll let you talk go you finish
we did a table read and and this was a
while ago this was two years ago right
so that's how long it takes for these
things to come together so we did a
table read and I thought well that was a
fun table read and I loved the script
and I hope something happens but I had
no attachment to you know getting a part
out of it because you just never know
with these things so then I gear
lighting to come together it was like
they brought me back that is nice that
is just so decent of them to remember
that I did this and you know brought me
back so again I was still on deck to
play the other role yes she was thing a
different role um
and we did another read and we did
another reading and different people but
still the same - and then the the stars
aligned and I heard basically I I
realized you know I was I had my lead
the entire time I had like a Epiphany
sure why am i you know I have the person
who's supposed to play the lead here and
then when I approached Wendy to see if
she'd want to do it and because it's a
risky role and a lot of actresses were
scared away and not Wendy although three
weeks prior I didn't get emailed her yes
she did and I said are you sure you want
me to do this I was like she's because
if you want to replace me you totally
can because I was freaked out it's a lot
yeah but we jumped right in feet-first
yeah I didn't give her any opportunity
to take back the offer like that I was
oh
yeah there's no one that goes you know I
basically like went to her house and
kidnapped her and I was like no I knew
she was trying to weasel out where was I
but I got I had a crisis of confidence
I understood I was like I don't know if
I can carry this off I'm sure that
something has happened we're here at
Sundance
by the way Congrats it's a huge deal you
know what I mean yeah I'm always curious
about the editing process I say it all
the time it's the final rewrite what did
you learn from any any early screenings
friends-and-family screenings that
impacted the finished film and if you
guys seen it yet we have yeah yeah I saw
it by myself I saw with a couple other
people from the cast some family stuff
like that I had at Deb's office so that
was fun like a slightly less than
finished version and I'm excited to see
like the full thing with all the energy
of like a big audience it's gonna be so
fun what did you learn from any
screenings that maybe did you change the
film at all based on any early
screenings um well
hi ed a-- today film as well but yeah i
mean you learn every time I don't really
grab early screenings I just showed
people that I trusted and would get
notes so there was just a couple people
like my husband and you know another
editor who came in for a couple weeks
who I polished the film with and I
basically worked with the same editor
most of the time and it was just a
rewriting process really and also just
letting go of stuff like I lost an
entire character really Oh in the Edit
mm-hmm is it weird but I always
overwrite knowing that it's got to be
cut down Jordan so I try to shoot as
much as I can and get as much content as
I can and I purposely overwrite the
scenes because I like to cut in to the
meat of the scene but I like to have the
actors bleed into it what is it like
picking up the phone to call whatever
the actor was and say hey you did
awesome
but yeah you didn't make the final cut I
haven't I'm scared I actually was asking
somebody about it but like there's this
one guy who didn't even have a speaking
role who just appeared like a couple
times who's cut out and he's posting all
over social media and I told her I think
he's so excited and I'm like
there was no you know he here what's he
getting fabulous no it's not here but it
was just that it wasn't necessary for
the telling of the story I completely
got it I really did before I run out of
time with you guys I just want to ask a
few quick questions it's basically get
to know your Sundance attendee for the
to act for I'm curious what what would
you guys like to guest star on and what
would you love to guest write and direct
I'd probably guest star on the gold
Birds that sounds like it would be fun I
bet we can make that happen you know
what could you tell me more about this
show the Goldbergs is it on TV well I've
heard such great things there seems to
be like some sort of silent secret
actress that's on it that nobody the
word diva a lot yeah yeah mmm
the way I clean my own trailer don't ask
for anything but you'd be great on that
and and and most things yeah you'd be
great on most things um I want to be on
something really gritty and ma Biche
okay not a comedy I want to be Tony
Soprano I heard they're making the
Saints of New York yeah that's that
James Gandolfini son is re yeah dammit
yeah he beat out I'm sending in a tape
called the many Saints of New York it's
a Newark my bad it's a prequel to The
Sopranos
I want to reign direct for that but I
think it's a feature though yeah just a
one movie thing not for TV I don't know
okay yeah I know my own content I have a
lot of scripts and a lot of I have
projects that I want to I completely see
you in do she has another film that
debuted at what South by Southwest
called before the Sun explodes it was
fabulous so you're gonna drop the f-bomb
no no no I censored myself I like one of
them but I didn't do it but you know we
did this film in three weeks what did
you say 2015 days TV and we did it and I
was like I don't know how this is gonna
add it together then I saw her other
movie and I thought I have no there
there's nothing to worry about
she's got her ish together
what film scared you guys as a kid oh
can I say that there was this this show
on channel 9 remember when there was
like only three channels but it was
about cannibalism I don't know the name
but it was like this family that brought
in these beautiful Corinne and they
would weigh them every night and then
they found them in the freezer that
freaked the hell out there's a lot about
horror movies do you know what movie
that was please fire it like they had a
creepy son and they would have these
beautiful women coming in and then they
would each disappear and they'd be like
where's Marie and she's like oh she left
this morning and then there's like one
girl left and she's wandering on
television when I was like six years
older I can tell you strong memory yeah
I don't know the title sure huh what
film scared you as a kid um jaws scared
me so much that I still have never seen
it it's the commercial the kind the way
people would talk about it and that it's
about sharks in general right
so are you someone that can go swimming
or no I can go swimming but I know the
times of day that that ocean sharks
would be out to combat speed yes yes I
was really scared of Willy Wonka in the
Chocolate Factory
but just the one scene where they're
like on the boat and it gets dark and
it's scary and there's fight yeah yeah
that is is there anything that you guys
collect oh I still have a rock
collection from when I was three just
like regular little rocks they're not
special special to me I know people that
pick up rocks when they travel and then
they save those and have that and they
label so it's like you take pieces with
from where they've been nice I collect
crystals do they have special powers I
don't know I think they're pretty and
they don't look like that until great
pressure has been applied in the earth
so you take apply that to your life
right okay
similarly seaglass Oh magic it is
magical yes but do you remember your
first you probably won't answer this
your first movie or TV show crush oh I
know what was his name
Blue Lagoon Christopher Atkins made an
impression on both of them apparently no
this is Andy Gibb's okay younger brother
who married Victoria Principal no is
whole life story
yeah I love Saturday Night Fever ISM and
Oh probably my like my first celebrity
crush was probably when I was like six
watching the Harry Potter movies for the
first time had a big crush on Emma
Watson yeah for sure knee of course
she's dreamy what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once and don't say the Goldbergs the
West Wing for sure
Oh king of the hill really yeah
that's Sopranos really that shows
fantastic uh do you have a favorite
superhero movie maybe Watchmen I really
enjoyed that sure it's super fun
you should have you seen the director's
cut like the extended version now I
haven't and you should absolutely do
that when you get back to wherever you
live watch the extended version
I promised it's even better I don't I
don't do this superhero thing mmm that
was just never my jam sorry I have kids
so I kind of tangentially maybe I kind
of liked the if I were to pick one that
I've sort of tangentially experienced
maybe ant-man sure Paul Rudd from Paul
Rudd yeah I like him the vampire I
really don't know this is one of these
things where it's like this or that
I'm just curious which one you're more
into Star Wars or Star Trek Star Wars
they're both like on the same plane for
me but if it start Trek for the more
vintage sure Game of Thrones are
Breaking Bad Breaking Bad Breaking Bad
that's tough I love them both so much
I've seen Game of Thrones more times
let's go with that okay
Han Solo or indiana jones indiana jones
and the jones there's my last question
for you guys do you know sometimes to
perform and sometimes it's a movie but
do you remember what got you into the
entertainment industry like what you saw
maybe and said oh my god I want to do
that
well for me when I was little I used to
replays so this is I don't know if this
I would say theater was my way in and it
was Tennessee William plays and Sam
Shepard plays
The Sound of Music hmm you saw it look I
saw it as a little kid and was like I
want to do that all of it all those
parts great even the Nazis
no fair enough yeah I started when I was
really little when I was like four I was
in daddy daycare and I just thought that
I was going and playing with a bunch of
kids for four hours a day yeah I was
tiny I still look exactly watch that
like a lot but I thought I was just like
playing around for four hours every day
with a bunch of other toddlers so it's
like oh this is great let's keep doing
this it's fun that's crazy
and amazing I mean it when I say
sincerely I cannot wait to see the movie
and I'm so I can feel the nervousness or
for the premiere tonight and I really
think it's gonna go well I have a good
feeling but seriously thank you so much
for coming in and are you psycho thanks
for having a good feeling I hope no I
I'm very confident really good I really
good feeling about this well then you're
excited to see the movie we're excited
for you to see the movie yes yes I'm
legitimately we'll be contacting you in
complement if this thing called Twitter
and after I see movies here I do these
things called tweets so it will be out
there I'll figure out what that is you
need to let your ballot well no great
it's a suite exactly I'm hey listen
thank you so much
you